[Music]
hey my name is anna and i'm working as a
science science manager here at the mdc
my name is jeremy morgan and i work as a
postdoc in fmp berlin
[Music]
i decided
for science i would say it was it's a
it's a it's probably a first-hand memory
it's like a teacher in school asked me
when i was like i think 11 or 12 years
if i want to participate in a
in a competition
for in a science competition for
teens and kids it's called human foster
experiment and then at the end i stayed
there i stayed there for five years i
think i did like five
five different projects i was planting
tomato plants and i was watching birds
and
i was working with students and what is
the best way to learn vocabulary
um yeah and then afterwards when i when
i already went to university i
participated in this
scientific competition as a as a
reviewer so that was i changed sides so
to say
yeah that was great experience
i
decided when i reached university
and i i knew i wanted to do something
which was somehow
logical and i had argument to it and i
was torn between
science and law
i didn't know which way i wanted to go
but i had a really good chemistry
teacher in high school
so shout out to gavin layton
who who made chemistry really enjoyable
and so then i decided i would do
undergraduate chemistry
and then from there i reached the end of
my degree and started working a kind of
normal job and found it was a lot less
interesting than i expected and so i
went from there into research and so
i did my phd and now now i work as a
postdoc still in in research
[Music]
a postdoc that's a super tough question
because it means so much it means
first of all it's a person and it's a
scientist but then
it depends so much on the topic
scientific background then also the
the work experience this person had
before the way how this person perceived
his or her
phd
um also how big is the lab you're
working in as a postdoc it's a very
small lab of a junior group leader
so do you have maybe very close
connection or is it huge lab where you
already have a leadership experience
because you are
responsible for master students and phd
students
and
in general it's a person who's doing
independent science and
yeah
scientific achievements
i think a postdoc as well is is multiple
different things i think it's a career
stage
if you want to go into academia a
postdoc is a professional scientist who
is looking to gain experience but who
also already has some skills so they are
typically the most highly trained
technical member of a lab
but at the same time they don't have the
burden of
searching for funding or
defending themselves in front of their
professorial colleagues
so they have more freedom and they can
really pursue maybe the hardest and most
challenging research questions
whilst
having i think the luxury to do nothing
else
so i think it's a really um
a really free stage of your career but
also
a very stressful one because you have to
be able to
produce something to show that you can
be a competent scientist
[Music]
so
the work of the postdoc a postdoc i
would say
is very broad because you are somehow
the least senior
management person and the most senior
lab person and so this means you often
are
the go-between between the principal
investigator the supervisor and the phd
students
and so
your primary task is research you spend
a lot of time
designing experiments executing them
depending on your position maybe you
have your own funding and you've
proposed your project and you're seeing
it through to completion or maybe you're
working on a project from the principal
investigator
but you also spend a lot of your time
mentoring and training
and
i've done
lecturing demonstrating in labs teaching
and it's really a broad position and
if you're on the academic track it's a
chance to
prepare yourself for how it would be
to be a professor
if you're more interested in leaving
academia then it's a chance to
gain skills
particularly collaboration skills or
communication skills that could be
useful
when you look for jobs in the company
further on
the work of a postdoc involves many many
different tasks and i think there are
also tasks you're maybe at the at the
beginning when you start this job not so
well aware of
and especially communication skills so
you you have a pi you have a you have a
person you're working with and like very
close cooperation you have to
communicate there what you want and this
you have to listen very well you have to
talk to your
phd students and master students if
you're supervising them but you also
have a huge
responsibility and task in communicating
your science and this means
either for public also on conferences
to to scientists so also to like to
people who who know the field very well
right to experts but also to lay people
and i think this is another big
challenge maybe people in the beginning
are not so well aware of when they start
a postdoc and then a third aspect of
communication to communicate with people
you want to have funding from and this
can be like as well experts as you but
maybe also scientists from another field
you have to communicate way broader your
ideas and you have to find the
the bigger picture picture so the
mission your scientific goals and this
acquires a lot of communication and
thinking
um what else
it's a lot of it's
it's also a lot of presenting it's
presenting yourself if you want to have
funding but it's also pretty how to
present your data in a in a format
for scientific
publication
in a well-structured
manner
[Music]
it's conducting experiments if you're in
the wet lab it's it's hands-on work and
it's very it's time-consuming this also
you have to remember
um it's like but it's also very creative
i loved it i loved it i loved conducting
experiments so yeah they're fans of it
and not so so much fun
yeah i think that's it i mean there are
millions of other things
[Music]
i'm
i think the big difference between
research as a postdoc and research as a
phd student
is that as a phd student you are there
to get a degree you're there to earn
your phd and so this means that the
scope of the projects that you can
undertake
is limited by
what it takes to get your degree maybe
the time or the resources available
whereas as a postdoc particularly if you
have your own funding you have full
license to
solely concentrate on the research
without some of the restrictions and
that means that typically you can take
on riskier projects because you're not
required to produce something in a
particular time frame like you would
with a phd or more challenging projects
because you're more experienced so i
would argue that typically the most
exciting breakthroughs um in science
come from postdoc research
postdoc reaches research is so important
because i think this is
this is a very very exciting time a very
special time in the life of a scientist
because you're you're done with your
degree you're not a postdoc you're not a
phd candidate or student anymore so you
don't want to have the
necessary the degree but you're also not
not on the pi level so where you have to
do a lot of administration organization
uh organizational stuff to do and this
is this is a time where you can allow
yourself to also have like
brave ideas and to follow up um
things no one else in the lab is
necessarily interested in
but but you are interested in and you
see the need in this and then you can
also and this will also later on help
you to
to convince others and also to convince
yourself right especially when you want
to decide do you want to stay in
academia or not as a scientist
um
this is why
yeah this is why research as a postdoc
is so important because it's it's a very
independent time a very brave creative
time a time where you can also
some things let's settle and then pick
them up after maybe three months again
and
yeah they have time to grow and to
develop ideas in this time because
you're not so much under pressure you
end up pressure and it's a very
competitive time
but things can also develop
[Music]
so
i think the most valuable qualities
are
resilience and patience because
the most challenging part about
scientific research is asking a question
and finding out the question or the
hypothesis you've proposed is wrong and
this is the most common outcome so most
of the time when you design an
experiment and you think you
know the answer or you hope for an
answer it doesn't happen
and so you repeatedly design experiments
until you can narrow down
what is going on and this
generally entails a lot of failure until
hopefully eventually you get a success
and so
i think
having the patience and the resilience
to tolerate all of that failure all of
those roadblocks until you
find the answer to the question you're
asking
is the most important quality
yeah i think it's
if you want to be a postdoc and you want
to be a happy postdoc you you need
passion scientific passion this is so
important you need to love what you do
and there will be days where you do not
love it
but i think if this comes back this is
the the perfect spirit and the perfect
drive and the long breath you need to be
you need to be patient with yourself
with others
uh also with the question that come up
with in your mind
and your ideas
um yeah so it's a long breath
[Music]
i think a lot of the challenges
are actually structural challenges
so
more and more people are
having the ability to enter into a
post-doc career
but
the positions that come afterwards in
academia are becoming more and more
limited so you always have this inherent
pressure to somehow stand out during
your post-doc if you want to
try and move into academia later
i think with that comes funding because
it's competitive for funding and so you
need to make a case for your research
and why you're the best person to
receive the money
but then also there's some of the
culture that comes with this in-between
position
um
it's it's generally better seen
if you leave the lab and maybe even the
country that you did your
initial training in and go far away to
somewhere else i mean
in my case as well um and this is really
hard and actually a lot of people
cannot do this
um
which makes access to doing a postdoc
itself kind of a luxury um
yeah yeah for me one the biggest
challenge
how can i summarize it as a lag it was a
lack of
time because i had the feeling i need to
spend a lot of time for my research so
there was
way little time for for other things to
do for for fun time for partner for
friends you're always in a in a in a in
a sandwich position there
or
lack of information and then we come to
this career options so um what can i do
next and also what is the next step
because you you are doing so individual
things that finding a mentor who's
really like
who's really case specific who's who can
support you very individually is very
very hard and
yeah sometimes lack of money lack of
funding as you said already
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
i think this is something that is
actually
a bit up for discussion at the moment in
academia because
increasingly most postdocs will not end
up working as an academic professionally
which means they need to find industries
where
their skills are valued and fit really
well
and
this shouldn't be so hard because
postdocs are highly trained they are
very capable
very intelligent problem-solving
people but translating those skills into
the language of people who might employ
them i think is the challenge
and so
the easiest transition
outside of academia is into other
science-based industries research in
pharmaceutical industry chemicals
industry biology industry but then also
in
investment banking when you're looking
for choosing your investments in
government policy in managing scientific
institutions there's a huge range of
possibilities but the link from the
institute or the university to
the
final position i think is only starting
to become really clear for a lot of
people and so
yeah i think it'll be interesting to see
how that changes and maybe i can add
another example you can also work as a
lecturer in in schools you can work
self-employed as a mentor a mentor for
for other scientists because you're well
trained you have the scientific
background
you know about challenges so you can you
can push and empower other people for in
in their scientific life so science
scientific writing medical communication
it's a big one an increasingly big one
especially when you have
big
societal problems pandemic climate
change you need to be able to
communicate you need people who are
dedicated to communicate science to the
public because this is not part of your
average scientist's training and you can
see this
with like mixed success across the whole
world as
epidemiologists try and explain what
what covert 19 is to the population
another example um editor scientific
editor
for for a scientific journal very still
very close to science to new findings
methods
the best advice for my certificate was
clearly that i should stay in science
and that may sound a bit odd or
broad but for me at that point it was
not clear what my options are and if i
want to stay in academia or not if i can
stay in academia and suddenly a person
from outside academia opened a window
for me for many many different options
job options there are
and then even i came back to consider a
job in academia you know but it's it's
really it opened my my mind and
also
my my passion again my scientific
passion
i think um
the best advice i
received was that building a career is
trial and error you can't
plan your way through it because you
don't know
what you're going to find how you're
going to feel about
a new role or a new position until you
try it and so it's not something you can
plan out until the end you have to see
what works and see what doesn't and if
it doesn't work
you can move on and try something else
and i think
coming from the story that
you're given as you go through your
higher education in academia which is
this is the track it's a straight road
you'll get to the end this idea that i
could try something new and maybe it
wouldn't work but that's fine and then i
could try something else afterwards was
shockingly innovative which which it
shouldn't have been but
that tells you how strong the the story
is how strong the narrative is um so
yeah this is the path or the
the perspective that i'll take now
because i'm trial and error
[Music]
[Applause]
you